today is the day that the window opens
for the application of the franchise tag
and the transition tag and josh this was
a two-day delay to accommodate the cba
negotiations and the window is opening
under the rules the current labor deal
which means every team has one franchise
tag
and
one transition tag usually it's one or
the other and this becomes a factor for
a couple of teams yes cowboys
titans maybe the buccaneers we really
don't know what they want to do with
james winston but the cowboys have amari
cooper the receiver they acquired in
trade from the raiders a year and a half
ago and quarterback dak prescott titans
have quarterback ryan tannehill and
running back derek henry and the
buccaneers have passed russia shaq
barrett and quarterback jameis winston
if they want to keep him and this
creates an awkward situation for these
teams now because the window's open
what do you do and i'm a big believer
that this is all deadline driven anyway
and what matters is when it closes not
when it opens but it is kind of a weird
thing that we've got the window opening
under this old set of rules while the
nfl players association tries to figure
out what they're going to do with the
cba proposal
it's a massive wrinkle the transition
tag plus the franchise tag because
in many other years you'd only have
either dak or amari cooper reach free
agency and we were listening to
mike mccarthy's press conference
yesterday and he was talking about how
in sync dak and amari were and it kind
of seems like a package for them moving
forward i mean in a new coach
with somewhat of a new system obviously
kellen moore is still going to be on
that coaching staff you want to keep
some type of continuity and explosion
and i think michael galp is a very good
player but i don't know how the cowboys
could look at themselves in the mirror
give his eco led contract prior to 2019
and then let a playmaker either it's not
going to happen with dak prescott but in
someone like mario cooper they obviously
traded high draft capital four hit the
open market so i would expect both to be
on the roster obviously heading in next
season well and ideally what the cowboys
would do is get dak prescott signed to a
contract before the tag deadline so they
could use the tag anamarie cooper if
ultimately the cba goes through and
there's only one tag available but what
an embarrassment it will be for the
cowboys if cooper hits the open market
and they can't resign him because
remember it was a year ago when they
were blustering about their first round
pick being amari cooper oh what are you
gonna do when you're on the clock well
we're gonna watch mari cooper film but
the thing is when you use that first
round pick for a guy who's in the middle
of his fourth season and he's got that
high level fifth year option and then
the franchise tag and you don't have a
franchise tag because you have not yet
been able to sign your quarterback and
he walks away that is a huge huge
embarrassment it's the kind of thing
that could get a gm fired if the gm
wasn't the owner of the team and the
relationship that he and dak had
especially against your minnesota
vikings last season
i mean look i have to build this don't
worry about getting make up for josh i
have to be a sheriff appropriately uh
his game against the vikings was
fantastic those sideline grabs those
contested catches
that is something you cannot break up
especially with a wide receiver like
omar cooper who's had a roller coaster
of a career he's had six to eight game
stretches that were
one of the best in the league at his
position than 68 games that were very
very quiet there seems to be consistency
now but when i look at the true
franchise tag across the nfl
just looking at the free agent list edge
rusher's defensive players it seems like
it's going to be the vast majority get
that and so then that allows me it makes
me think that that second level group
ones either get cut maybe like olivier
vernon or
shaq barrett who
is coming off just one season of
fantastic play it's something that i'm
not sure how much i would pay them long
term right
that a tag just giving them an extra
year in their same system just makes no
sense well and you know there's a
dynamic we saw last year with with edge
rushers frank clark and d ford you tag
them and then you trade them and you get
a heck of a lot for them rather than
letting them leave as free agents and
have that departure factor in to the
compensatory draft pick formula the
following year if you can get a first
round pick in the second round pick for
frank clark tag and trade him if you can
get a second round pick for d ford tag
and trade him so maybe that's what the
jaguars do with yannick and gawkway
maybe that's what the buccaneers
although i think the buccaneers are
determined to keep shaq barrett barrett
has said enough to imply that he's
willing to do a reasonable deal with the
bucks to stay put he's very conscious of
the tax rate in florida which is zero
he doesn't want to play for a california
team where it's 13.3 percent so i think
he's he's sent the signal that he's
willing to be reasonable to stay with
the buccaneers but you know for yannick
way i think he's done in jacksonville i
really want i think he wants out of
jacksonville
and
they tag him i think tag and trade is a
very real possibility if janik and gagwe
was on a more prolific team i think he
would be considered one of the best edge
rushers in the nfl he's got 37 sacks
37.5 in four years he's a fantastic
player and i i understand some
frustration because i don't know if it's
the jaguar's number one priority in 2020
to win football games in jacksonville
right now i mean spending two games in
london
keeping the same losing franchise both
from the general manager and head coach
perspective
the reason i brought up olivier vernon
zame and someone like robert quinn is if
matt judon gets tagged
chris jones as well these second tier
players because ferdinand saw in the
browns might not be for much longer they
might be the ones who are the
beneficiaries with major contracts when
it was remember it was vernon who got
the major contract
when von miller was caught in the
franchise tag and von miller was like
what's going on here could be vernon
again yeah um
this is
an interesting group
in that
it's a very good edge rushing and
defensive line class as well
so how does that
wrinkle throw into this whole mismatch
and conundrum plus you have the entire
davian cloudy conversation here and
clown is a fascinating case because in
his trade deal it was said that he
cannot be franchise tagged
would a team really page davey and
clowny as the number one defensive
contract in the nfl someone who might
not be known for his past rushing
prowess at least statistically yet on
the field when he is on he's one of the
most dominant forces in the nfl right
it's not sax it's chris sims patent
pending statistic i can't say that here
f up the play yes we can say f up the
play and that's what javian clowney does
he creates havoc he destroys things he
he blows the play up and keeps the
offense from doing what it wants to do
the problem with clowney though is
every time you think it's finally
falling together he ends up with some
sort of an injury he had that dominant
performance on the monday night against
the 49ers in santa clara game of his
career right and i think without him
that night the seahawks don't win the
game and then we hear that he had a
sports hernia core muscle injury
whatever label you apply to it that
began to hurt him during the game it
hampered him the rest of the season
and uh you know that's the caveat for a
guy like for a guy like jadavian clowney
because you're paying for the hope right
that he can be the guy that we saw that
monday night more than once a year and
ideally you know on a regular basis how
do you feel of aj green's situation
right now this is a player who's given
so much of the bengals
eight what plus years had some fantastic
seasons you know they made they've made
the playoffs i believe he's played four
times never gotten out of the first
round
but you have to think in his position
the grass is greener like
this is the time in his career to be on
a good team but it might not be
by his choice because they obviously can
franchise tag him you have the number
one overall pick joe burrow is almost
certainly headed in that direction and
so you have to have some setup for
success and you have good skill position
players around him right tyler boyd john
ross joe mixon was one of the best
running backs in the league during the
second half of last season but is really
aj greene going to be thrilled to be
playing in that situation now this late
in his career part of the problem for aj
green is he is not wired to take a stand
he's not wired to hold out he's not
wired to come out and say i don't want
to be here anymore when julio jones was
holding out and trying to get more money
and toying with the possibility of a
training camp hold out aj green came out
and said i support him i wouldn't do it
but i support him if he does it so you
know sometimes teams get a read on a
guy's personality and they take
advantage of it they know the guy isn't
going to draw a line and stay away and i
think the reality with the bengals they
got to ask themselves what are they
going to get out of them if they tag him
he didn't play at all last year exactly
so you're you're making a huge financial
investment and that's something the
bengals typically don't like to do
and i think we could see a scenario
where they tag him and maybe don't trade
him right away but tag him see how
things play out see how the early stages
of the season go
and then this time around they do what
we thought they were going to do last
year which is trade him at the trade
deadline that that could be what they do
but the other thing about the bengals
when you're dealing with an
unconventional team
we can't apply conventional analysis and
prediction to what we think a team a
rational well-run team sorry cincinnati
but i mean i don't know why all of a
sudden it's a hot take that the bengals
aren't good and it's not a good football
organization it's been proven year after
year time and again i still think marvin
lewis should be there i think he was
underrated and not appreciated for what
he did for that team because of all the
obstacles starting with the reluctance
to spend the kind of money that you need
to spend to have a great organization
but i i i could see them
tag him keep him eventually trade him
and then this road also leads back to
derek henry as well we started this
conversation with the franchise tag plus
transition tag well if that is off the
table which do you think is more likely
derek henry gets a long-term contract
ryan tano gets a long-term contract
it would make sense to go in the
quarterback route but he's also the one
who's been on the team for a less amount
of time he also impacts the team
in a much larger way even though we all
believe derek henry is a very very
talented player uh it just has shown the
past few big money second year contracts
the running back position just certainly
have not you instantly regret it todd
there's no way the rams would sign todd
gurley to the contract they signed him
to two years ago they regretted it after
one season and you could say the cowboys
look at what they got last year from
ezekiel and say man we really shouldn't
have done that so you have to be careful
when you're heading in that direction
derrick henry's a bit of diff a
different case though we have seen him
being used more and more we've seen his
production go up and you just wonder is
he entering now truly prime years and
what do you want the incentive to be in
those prime years you could tag him this
year
and continue to feed that incentive that
desire to go out and perform have a 2000
yard season which i think josh he's
capable of if he played all year long
like he does the second half of the
season he would have 2 000 yard season
it's such a small sample size mike
because even 16 games when you look at
it from a large picture is a small
sample size we only about have half of
that 10 games a little more than that
with the tennessee titans and you know
bringing the band back together i think
is fun and the titans were one of the
more exciting teams down the stretch
obviously we saw what they did in the
playoffs and they can even improve i
mean aj brown really didn't hit his
stride until the second half of last
year and i mean ryan taylor was one of
the best play action passers
statistically in the nfl i do worry i do
worry about paying a back like derek
henry again i love him i he's one of the
best fourth quarter closer today
brown i think he's today's jim brown the
way he runs he is not effective in the
passing game right now as
when i look at second contract running
backs alvin kamara christian mccaffrey
absolutely stand out as
players i think would be worth it
because they are so multi-dimensional
they are so diverse and how you can use
them in their effectiveness derek henry
is a totally different style it fits in
the identity and i think that's great
with the titans but it took them a while
to get obviously to this identity that
they have there's a weird vibe with the
titans and ryan tannehill also
and i can't really figure out where
they're coming from now i understand it
with the buccaneers and jameis winston
he threw 30 interceptions ryan tannehill
only had the fourth highest single
season passer rating of all time
and he was even though they didn't
overuse him when they used him he made
good throws he made good decisions now i
worry about his injury history he played
with a reckless abandon last year that i
wouldn't want him playing with if i made
a major investment in him and i think
that's the thing you immediately worry
about if you give ryan tannehill a big
contract is he going to suffer another
torn acl is he going to have some other
sort of injury is there going to be a
regression and i just between mike
frable the head coach and john robinson
the gm i wonder what they are thinking
about behind door number two there's
been so much steam about tom brady but
whether it's tom brady or phillip rivers
or someone else i just can't help but
wonder whether they think ryan tannehill
has taken the team as far as he can and
if we want to go next level yep we need
one of these other guys there's one for
agent that is not getting enough love
arc armstead is the name uh the edge
rusher interior defense and he may get
tagged he can still get tagged i think
so he could he could they're at about 13
million and the cap can obviously
fluctuate with anything
but there were times this year obviously
deforest buckner nick bosa got all the
love but they were multiple game
stretches where eric armstead would be
the number one player in that defense
and it helps to have steve ford
absolutely
and it's also funny how these things
happen in contract years yeah well we'll
see how that plays out for eric armstead
and the 49ers and everybody else who's
about to be afraid
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports